and alex cobb who has pitched so well on
this mound
great to have him back off the il
was terrific in his first start back
[Applause]
busted bat
mayfield on the run
gets the out
siri
to left
goslin is there and he makes a catch
knocks it to center marshes over lines
it up makes the catch
alex cobb
one two three
back in anaheim lance mccullers is on
the mound for your houston astros as
they finish up this season series
against the
los angeles angels in 26 starts lance
has some
very good numbers 12-4 record 3.11 era
on the ground
backhanded nicely by altuve gets rid of
it in a hurry and yuli does his thing
another pick at first base by julie
guriel and a nice play by altuve
great play by altuve they are playing
marsh in that pull shift
he had to range far to his right made a
pickup on a tough hop
oh beautiful breaking ball outside
corner
ohtani jumped away thinking he might
have drawn a walk but that broke right
over
ground ball right side two big hops for
jose altuve
and two ground outs and a strikeout for
lance mccullers jr in a very solid start
to this one
hit hard that's a fair ball walsh cuts
it off cobb is over and gets the out
nicely done and walsh is such a gifted
first baseman his range a 1-2 count and
that's outside corner
love the motion you talked about the
glove side run back to the plate
he knew he had
caught the corner you could see him skip
right off the mound
charged by altuve feels it on the grass
and short right and throws out walsh
ground ball towards the left side of the
infield alex bregman the only one there
against rojas
how about lance mccullers jr back and
forth we go as he and alex cobb are
dealing early
that's that's that's an incredible
sequence
jammed him
for me rich that's better than the
strikeout
[Applause]
see suzuki's numbers against mccullers
that'll now be 0 for 10 as he hits a 2
hopper to alex bregman a little bit of a
high throw and a little bit wide and
healy guriel takes care of it from there
one two count to ring hifo there's one
out nobody on no score the pitch
breaking ball and it's a swing and a
miss mccullers gets ringfo on strikes
that's his second of the ball game two
away lance trying to match zeroes with
alex cobb through three innings
and he will as this fly ball into
shallow center is caught by carlos
correa for the final out of the inning
both pitchers going through three in
perfect fashion
right back to the mound off the glove of
cobb with serious speed no chance yeah
put in your pocket
a play that could have and probably
should have been made but
jose siri is going to pick up a base hit
here for the first hit of the game
[Applause]
bregman into center field that'll loop
in for a hit siri is going to go first
the third with no problem
that is getting it done from first to
third for jose siri on the little
looping single by alex bregman i agree
it's actually a great read on his part
too realizing that that ball wasn't hit
all that hard and now they're loaded the
astros have had a number of big innings
against the angels in his four-game set
outside corner you know what it doesn't
happen often where hitter realizes
he got him he knew it
[Applause]
[Music]
up the middle red heapho to the bag for
the outs
alex cobb pitches out of a bases loaded
spot
[Applause]
and the pitch flare into left center
field coming in hard unable to get to
that one is myers and that will drop in
so a bloop hit off the bat
of marsh
angel center fielder hit it out near the
astro center fielder but that falls in
that's the angel's first hit of the
night
on the ground
yuli will flip it to correa
and no chance for the double play
angels have runners at first and third
and now walsh will be the batter
walsh
high
right field deep
siri at the wall makes the catch
tagging is marsh it's one nothing
as he grounds one towards short correa
makes the play and that'll do it for the
angels but they score the first run of
the night they do so with one hit and
one walk it's one nothing
los angeles
chaz mccormick loops one into right
center and jazz mccormick has himself a
flare hit
a tube a little tapper cobb bare hands
and whips it to first in time that's a
great play using the bare hand pushing
it
[Applause]
on the grass and then coming up quickly
like an infielder getting out
got him kind of with a fastball suzuki
goes down on strikes lance has three
strikeouts
got him
breaking ball down luis randhifo
goes down on strikes back-to-back
strikeouts for mccullar
try it again
and he did yes
bob gets the first out of the six that
was nasty he threw three great splitters
now it's bregman's turn bregman is one
for two with a single
bregman left field gosling back
and at the track he reaches that makes
the catch the goose spreading his wings
at the end to make the play cobb will
face carlos correa with runners on burst
in third and two outs
correa laces one to center field for a
base hit in the score tucker we're tied
at one carlos correa rbi 88 on the air
so one out and here's ohtani
wow that's a good pitch it is a great
pitch and he didn't get it mccullough's
isn't happy ohtani
walks there goes ohtani's on the move
pitch a ball throw to second safe is the
call
and shohei has his
24th
stolen base walsh big lead at first
ohtani's at second mayfield in a big
spot with two outs
line drive left field
into the corner here comes ohtani he
will score here comes walsh he will
score
three wood angels captain oh captain my
captain clutch
jose rojas the batter
on the ground towards al tube bobbles it
and rojas will reach here comes mayfield
trying to score diving tagged by
maldonado he's out at home plate martine
making a diving play to save a run from
scoring
speed on the bases wong marsh ohtani
from third to first
on the ground to third and bregman will
step on the bag and get the horse out on
marsh to end the inning
taylor gets out of a jam it's still 3-1
as we head to the eighth
castro the final hope for the astros
pinch hitting for maldonado astros down
by two
castro hits it deep to center field all
the way back is marge this ball's gone
jason castro off the bench with a pinch
hit home run
another close and late at bat for castro
that comes through with a bomb
three to two angels two outs altuve at
first in the top of the ninth
here's the pitch did he go after that
one let's see on the appeal they say he
did the first base umpire rings up siri
and the ball game is over
and as it turns out iglesia strikes out
the side the angels hold on in the ninth
they beat the astros three to two